today will forever be known as trailer
thursday because there's a lot of them
we're talking about the uncharted movie
trailer we're talking about a halo
infinite pc overview trailer a trailer
for the new battlefield 2042 specialist
as well as a new trailer for the apex
legends new season my name is davonte
chisholm and you're watching
trailer spot news
following a leak the trailer for the
long awaited uncharted movie has finally
arrived and reactions to it aren't as
bad as i was expecting the film stars
tom holland and is directed by
zombieland's ruben fleischer in a blog
post naughty dog said quote ruben
feister shared that he made the movie
for both hardcore fans of the game and
those who are not yet familiar with the
franchise and believe that both will be
equally entertained by this incredibly
fun and action-packed film
the uncharted movie also stars big names
like antonio banderas and mark wahlberg
so have you seen the trailer yet what do
you think of it because personally i
still don't buy mark wahlberg as sully
that's that's just me all they had to do
was a little bit of this
and it would have completely sold it for
me i know it's supposed to be like a
younger version of the characters but
even in uncharted 3 we see a younger
sully and guess what he had a stash
i want to see the
stash switching gears from sony to
microsoft because halo infinite
developer 343 industries released a pc
overview trailer for the upcoming sci-fi
shooter in the video 343's joseph staton
said quote we are really building it
from the ground up to be a great game
for pc players who love to customize the
experience the way they want to the
video also touches on a huge range of
other elements of the pc edition
including ultra wide support frame rate
settings and a variety of other pc
options like triple key bindings and
many different control configurations
adding to this the company also revealed
that it will be working with amd to
bring ray tracing to the game after
launch but did not mention if ray
tracing will be featured in both the pc
and console editions
but the trailers don't stop there dice
also dropped a new video that revealed
the final five specialist characters
that will be featured in battlefield
2042 at launch specialist characters
represent a big change for the
battlefield series which has in the past
relied on more rigid class types but not
distinct characters like in 2042 these
new specialists include navin rayo a
recon soldier whose trojan network trait
reveals enemies around them after
killing a hacked target santiago
espinosa an assault character that
wields a ballistic shield and can
survive blasts better than others emma
rozier another assault character who can
fly with the wingsuit and has a variety
of smart explosives jisoo pake who is a
recon soldier who can detect nearby
enemies and use a scanner to reveal the
location of hostiles and cover and
constantine angel a support character
who can heal teammates faster than
normal and drop a crate that lets
players switch loadouts and also
contains armor and ammo for teammates
and speaking of new things coming to
your favorite shooters respawn announced
a new apex legends map a new trailer for
the game's upcoming season escape shows
off beaches jungles and strange features
of what looked to be an upcoming vr map
along with ash the newest legend the
trailer kicks off with the game's cast
relaxing on the beach which only lasts
for so long before monstrous wildlife
begins attacking the spiders from the
trailer hint that we're on planet gaia
but it's not clear what role these
monsters will play when the map actually
launches or if they'll interact with the
players at all it's possible that the
monsters will simply be window dressing
for the map that being said a page on ea
site going over the event says quote no
matter how beautiful it seems every
corner of outlands is a dangerous place
you'd be wise to remember that
like i said a lot of trailers
i don't know about you but
me and nate we're gonna go watch the
uncharted trailer again and try to
come up with some uh some really
concrete opinions on it i think we're
gonna go see it in theaters right all
right well i guess we're gonna go see it
no matter how we feel about the trailer
i'll see you tomorrow